Man hat dir gesagt, dass Kermit jetzt
die Rainbow Connection aufführt und
es geht weiter mit mir.
Ja, es ist eine Ehre für mich, nach Kuba zu kommen. Wir sind
sehr nett, Peter. Ja, und Peter ist unser
Mann. Ja,
okay, hier machen wir drei, zum Beispiel: Gibt es
so viele Lieder darüber?  Regenbögen und
das ist eine gute, gute Frage.
Ja, sie folgt unseren Visionen, aber für mich
haben Illusionen und Regenbögen nichts mit
mir zu tun.
Was denkst du darüber, was uns
gesagt wurde und einige glauben daran,
aber ich weiß, dass sie falsch liegen? Warte ab und sieh,
eines Tages werden wir  Ich werde es finden, The Rainbow
Connection, die Liebhaber, die Träumer und
ich.
Ich denke, Sie sollten diesen nächsten
Kauf tätigen. Okay, versuchen Sie es
beschäftigt und was
wir eines Tages finden werden. The Rainbow
Connection, die Liebenden, die Träumer.
Oh, sehr schön, okay, danke, danke